this studio
in a sense operates in a silo and that
their whole sole existence is to be the
steward of Halo that is their whole
thing is to handle everything Halo
related so when it comes to they have
their own publishing they have their own
consumer products they have their own
media inside of Microsoft this is a
special like team it's like a special
forces in a way right just your sole
purpose is Halo right so if I look at
that and I hate to do it but we gotta we
gotta pull out the resumes since you've
been since they've been in existence and
I've said this a little bit before and
fast I don't care what nobody say Master
Chief Collection is literally unplayable
and a disaster of a launch I remember I
wanted to get people to to get the Xbox
One people were like yo I'm interested
I'll wait for that I love those Halo
games they remastered the old ones
remember they did the the presentation
the here's before here's the new